irgendwann sind wir
wollen unsere freiheit wir haben so
carina thiele ist nicht nur im gegnerin
sie ist auch pflegefachkraft für sie
gilt ab dem 16 märz die impfpflicht der
grund besonders gefährdete gruppen
schützen die meisten corona drohten gibt
es bei den über 80-jährigen in dem
pflegeheim in dem corina thiele arbeitet
sind in den vergangenen vier monaten
zehn bewohner an corona gestorben sie
will sich dennoch nicht impfen lassen
sollte das auch jeder frei entscheiden
können weil es ist mein körper ist meine
gesundheit und die gesundheit der
heimbewohner corina thiele ist ihre
freie entscheidung wichtiger
ob ich mich einen stecker ob ich einen
schweren verlauf kriege das kann ich mit
und ohne impfung kriegen das impfen
nichts bringt glauben auch ihre
freundinnen die heute zu besuch kommen
auch sie arbeiten in der pflege
[Musik]
sie misstrauen wissenschaft und politik
informieren sich stattdessen auf youtube
und intel gramm gruppen
hinter solchen warnungen standen auch
knallharte eigenen interessen geld
millionenzahlungen an die krankenhäuser
das ist gezüchteter wehr gesetzt ich
glaube es ist eine biomasse das ist eine
biologische waffe und was wir jetzt
aktuell haben ist ja schon ein
bürgerkrieg nur mit glaubhafter weise
wissen mit anderen kommen sie nicht mehr
weiter und ich sage auch es ist geplant
das war von vornherein geplant das denke
ich auch bei den menschen zu viel wird
ja
in der pflege arbeiten rund 1,7
millionen beschäftigten schätzungsweise
11,2 prozent davon sind ungeimpft das
sind etwa
187.000 mitarbeiter bundesweit
ab dem 16 märz sollen nur noch geimpfte
in der pflege arbeiten so will es das
gesetz doch ob es so kommt unklar in den
heimen von frank winter arbeiten viele
ungeimpfte in einer der einrichtungen
sind über ein drittel nicht geimpft er
will niemanden kündigen
[Musik]
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich setze die
leute nicht ins aus als in die
mitarbeiter und sage du kommst am 15
dritten nicht mehr auf arbeit ist steht
nicht im gesetz dass er nicht mehr
beschäftigt werden darf auch
geschäftsführer zwinger ist ungeimpft
und will abwarten ob die behörden das
gesetz auch wirklich durchsetzen
wenn man einfach so schaut das war jetzt
schon eine personal not haben dann
möchte ich gerne wissen wer uns hilft
beziehungsweise wie wir das zukünftig
schaffen wollen die die noch mehr
pflegebedürftige und haben wie man die
noch versorgen also wollen wir das
personal her nehmen anstatt das
gesundheitsamt hier entscheiden sie über
beschäftigungsverbote amtsärztin renate
koch muss abschätzen was wichtiger ist
die gesetzliche impfpflicht durchsetzen
oder sicherstellen dass pflegebedürftige
in der pandemie überhaupt noch betreut
werden sie fühlt sich überfordert
keine ärztliche aufgabe
keine aufgabe die ein mediziner
erledigen sollte das würde auf sehr
wackligen beinen stehen und wir
befürchten dann eben wirklich und das
ist objektiv sicherlich so
wirklich exorbitante schadensansprüche
von beiden seiten sie hat angst vor
klagen pflegeheime die schadensersatz
fordern pflegekräfte die wegen
verdienstausfall vor gericht ziehen und
angehörige die auf eine angemessene
betreuung bestehen
das gesundheitsamt steht hier mit
sicherheit mit dem rücken an der wand
das resultiert aber auch aus dem
wirrwarr der gesetzgebung muss jetzt
einfach offen gesagt werden
rückendeckung bekommt die amtsärztin von
der landrätin des ilmkreises
und glaser wann genau eine behörde ein
beschäftigungsverbot aussprechen soll
der bundesgesetzgeber sagt dazu momentan
nichts und müssen sich vorstellen wir
haben hier in
der bundesrepublik deutschland haben wir
über 400 landkreise und kreisfreie
städte und jeder landkreis und jede
kreisfreie stadt würde dann ihre eigenen
kriterien festlegen das versteht kein
mensch ich sehe das außerordentlich
kritisch es gibt keine
bundeseinheitlichen regelungen dazu dort
wo die impfpflicht für pflegekräfte
beschlossen wurde fordern sie das gesetz
schnell anzuwenden wie immer bei solchen
gesetzen ist es so dass die bundesländer
die entsprechende konkrete umsetzung
organisieren müssen und dann natürlich
die kommunale ebene gefordert ist das
umzusetzen und dafür wird jetzt alles
getan dass man die umsetzung so so
unaufwendig wie möglich gestaltet
politisches wunschdenken
bei der ambulanten pflege der caritas in
berlin sind zwar 90 prozent geimpft
trotzdem befürchten sie dass hier nicht
alle versorgen können wenn die
impfpflicht in kraft tritt sie arbeiten
jetzt schon am limit bernd meyer stellt
aktuell 35 hausbesuche am tag
ich erwarte schon werden jetzt ab 16
märz tatsächlich von heute auf morgen
zehn prozent unserer mitarbeiter
wegfallen naja dann müssen entweder wir
die wir geimpft sind den rest mit
erledigen und ich weiß nicht ob ich 40
45 schaffte am tag keine ahnung
die geschäftsleitung der caritas geht
davon aus dass bald angehörige bei der
pflege mithelfen müssen sie waren hier
ursprünglich für die impfpflicht doch
nun stehen sie vor der frage wie sie den
dienstplan für märz noch besetzen sollen
ich möchte dass die einrichtung
spezifische impfpflicht ausgesetzt wird
und ich möchte durch aus dass wir weiter
an dem thema impfung arbeiten wir müssen
immer noch eigentlich die überzeugung
haben dass wir nur durch gespräche und
nicht durch druck die mitarbeiterinnen
in der pflege halten können ob wirklich
alle durch gespräche zu erreichen sind
bei carina thiele eher unwahrscheinlich
die bundesregierung bleibt bei ihrer
ansage die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht soll kommen
das gesetz gilt und ist umzusetzen
diese besonders vorhaben menschen müssen
wir schützen im thüringischen ilmkreis
stoßen die vorgaben aus berlin auf
unverständnis
dieses gesetz lässt sich schlichtweg zu
durch die gesundheitsämter nicht
umsetzen also bei uns im landkreis haben
wir über 40 pflegeeinrichtungen wir
haben zwei krankenhäuser und wenn man
jetzt davon ausgeht dass gegebenenfalls
zehn oder 20 prozent nicht geimpft sind
dann muss ich ihnen ganz ganz ehrlich
sagen denn das gesundheitsamt hier
prüfen soll die einzelteile prüfen soll
das kann das gesundheitsamt überhaupt
nicht schaffen diese kapazitäten haben
wir nicht die impfpflicht in der pflege
droht zu scheitern bevor sie überhaupt
in kraft tritt pflegenotstand oder
ungeimpfte pflegekräfte beides geht auf
kosten der gesundheit
schutzbedürftiger